hello welcome back to big mood
we got a member missing today but who we
got now
tiff and you got gina and nikki
and today we took your breakup
situations from instagram
if you're not following us on instagram
we are at big mood girls follow us
for show we're gonna start posting more
don't worry like we haven't been posting
but
we're gonna post and we frequently
posting stories asking for
your uh either your assumptions about us
or
your um relationship situations and you
could submit them to us and we will
give you your uh some solicited advice
because you've solicited it from us
you asked us you and since you asked us
it is an open forum yep for us
to tell you whether or not you should
break up yep so if you ever wanted to be
featured in one of our episodes that's
the way to do it
at least your story be featured because
i think i think we just
uh we assume you want to stay anonymous
so unless you explicitly say you like
please say my name then
then we'll shout you out but no one has
ever yeah no one has ever asked that so
just assume you're gonna be anonymous
can we make up names for them like oh
this is submitted by dickpuncher143
yes you know i'm sorry i'm gonna start
making up names for you guys
but i think you need to hear the story
first and then no the before the story
no i don't i don't care if she's talking
about like my husband and i
have a baby and i hate it her name is
dick puncher
it's that damn she has
but she's a dick puncher yeah she's
[ __ ] shoes her punchers don't like
babies yeah she's
trying to avoid having a baby right yeah
she punches dicks and not having to give
me this
dick gave me this baby right i tried to
punch it so many times and i'm still
pregnant
she punched it with her [ __ ] that's why
oh my god
all right well give me a name for this
one this first one okay
uh this is ask clincher 16.
just always full of tension
that's not just 16. there we go her
giggles are amazing
i love you jess i miss you i hope you
wish okay it says
this is my first real relationship after
being in some very toxic scenarios
he is the best boyfriend so sweet and
caring does everything right but for
some reason i never want to have sex
with him
and feel more of a friendly vibe
he's made it clear he misses sex and
wants it more often
i miss being single and don't love being
tied down but i'd never
cheat ever and also can't figure out if
i'm self-sabotaging because he's so
great or if
our relationship is just missing
something like sexual chemistry
also he is an immigrant and i feel
really pressured to be the one for him
for him and get married so he can become
a citizen but i don't even
but i don't think i even want to get
married to anyone you know
help i don't want to hurt him and i'm so
contradicted
if we break up i'll worry if we break up
i'll worry about him
and miss him but if we stay together i'm
bored you can still be friends
but i think you know in your heart
you're not supposed to be together yeah
yeah
and you shouldn't get married out of
obligation no
starting immigrants it's never gonna
work out and especially if he likes you
if he's in love with you
and you don't feel the same way back
it's just that's just even
more hurtful yeah yeah i really feel
like that
immigrant part of it is probably
like i think it's a huge reason why she
probably feels
no sexual chemistry like it's it's a
huge block
for her to not allow herself to get that
close because she feels that pressure
you know what i mean it could be
i'm assuming also some people just they
have compatibility but no chemistry and
sometimes people get those things
confused they think if they have one
they have both
yeah but they're completely separate so
that's why you can have bomb sex with a
really toxic guy
but you have no compatibility with a
life situation or you could have
everyone's
he's really good on paper like you
should totally
marry him if you just like saw what he
was on paper but then you get together
and you're like oh i just have something
in me doesn't want to have sex
there's no chemistry then and that
pressure of being like well
if i break up with him he's going to
have to leave the country like that's no
he shouldn't be with him because of that
obligation
no and he can find another person you're
not the only
girl out there like and so there's
probably someone that matches with him
and
it gives both of you a better
opportunity for happiness because you're
clearly
not happy even though you feel like you
should be because logically you should
be
but sad thing is is you know love's not
logical yeah so
that's usually the first thing that goes
when i feel like i'm not in the
relationship anymore and i just
yeah the sex goes yeah that is the very
first thing that goes for me too
totally and she still can and she was
concerned about like what if i'm
self-sabotaging
uh i don't know because when it comes to
sex is a very like
big part of the relationship yeah yeah
so if you don't get it
anymore yeah that's that's probably your
sign
now you need to go back to the streets
and and unclaim to your butthole
pack it up let me clench it but he'll be
free
yeah and back to the streets you go back
to the streets
yeah i agree i think it's back to the
streets too yeah and even though you
haven't cheated i mean that means you
have
high integrity but it doesn't mean that
like you belong together
yeah mm-hmm you clearly still care for
this person
but it doesn't mean you have to be there
like romantically anymore and there are
other great guys
out there that you will have actual
chemistry with so good luck to you back
on those streets
and it's her first relationship too like
get out there
her first healthy relationship oh
healthy relationship i see she said
her yeah because she said she was in
some toxic scenarios in the past well
now you know what's out there
so you you've got a flavor like okay i
like this from this guy and
this from this other guy like i need
chemistry but i also need there to be
this
good guy ship out there right that's
true you're refining your list
your like standards mm-hmm well good
luck
good luck ass clincher all right what's
the name for this next one uh this one
is uh titty puncher 14. titty puncher
14.
they're just destroying it
the first 13 were taken 14. all right
titty punch of 14.
go ahead so they say hey girls i love
every single one of you so so
so much and want nothing but the best
for your heart
i'm 23 and been watching everything jk
for years y'all provide me with
a companion in my [ __ ] y'all provided me
with a companion in my shitty early
teens
but there is no doubt in my mind you all
have been even more influential
part of my life since you all started
big mood
my boyfriend is 29 it's six years jess i
love you so much lol
don't worry jess isn't here to judge uh
he has a three-year-old
i've been with him for two years he's
changed a lot in that time span
am i am i wrong for saying it's still
not enough for me
i'm also afraid all the bad things that
have happened will never leave my mind
when my anxiety is trash it's all i
think about and will physically make
myself sick replaying it i only i
honestly feel like i'm being taken
advantage of because i'm the type of
person that if i got
if i got it we got it but i just don't
know what to do anymore
when we got together i was going to
school paying my own bills
in a new city while he was living with
his
with his parents doing drugs drinking
and had no type of money management
he's living with me now i'm paying
everything even child support some
months
we're done that's all i need to hear yep
well there's more
when he when he first moved in he agreed
he
we would have everything he spends an
absorbent amount of money
on weed and didn't doesn't he you're
paying for everything but he's spending
money all his money on weed
and doesn't have money for diapers oh
hell no what the [ __ ] this is selfish
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah the other drug i thought he quit
um until i found until i found it while
doing his laundry after he told me i
don't even want it anymore i didn't
think it would
be that easy to stop cold turkey she
continues
the drinking he would hide in his
regular cup and i didn't find out until
i drank out of his on accident
oh okay so there's lying
there's money mismanagement there's
selfishness
drug use there is taking advantage of
you
for financial and child support
not giving me a lot of reasons to stay
no is there anything
redeeming about him right is it just the
comfort level
yeah she continues she says there's a
lot of things that have happened between
us because of those three topics i have
terrible memories along with it he's
told me countless things him and his
exes have done
i've only been with one other guy it
made me feel inferior i guess
not knowing what i was doing when we
first got together and he would tell me
all of these things
to even him telling me sexual things
between him and the mother of his child
i don't like him i don't like that i
don't like it yeah i don't know jess
would be having a heart attack right now
yeah yeah she would be raging her
ancestors
are rolling in their graves jeez her
skin would be bright red
oh yeah she says i honestly can't get
that out of my head
and i think it's always going to be
engraved in my head he's incapable of
telling the truth so i don't even
believe him when he says he loves me
i'm sorry it's so long if y'all can't do
it in the episode i understand well this
could have been short
break up yeah holy [ __ ] i mean kill him
you're like you have a laundry list
of erase him from earth no
yeah has a child any reason that he
doesn't buy diapers for
right right i could also see her feeling
like she needs to stay to even protect
the kid
from his like yeah her deadbeat dad
jesus right as a mom but i mean if i
mean yeah
yeah for sure because i'm thinking like
if diapers if she has to
provide diapers she has to pay for child
support sounds like he's
making it seem like he can't pay for
diapers so she'll pay for it so he can
spend his money on weed
exactly what a piece of [ __ ] yeah dude
no leave out of here yeah no redeeming
quality whatsoever hello
if a man can't even take care of
something as basic and essential as
diapers
then why are you for a child yeah for a
child that is completely healthy can't
put his child's needs ahead of his own
yeah and especially the age of 29 like
that's not like oh he's 21 he's still
whatever
right he's 29 a full-grown full-on adult
his brain is already fully formed
exactly no there's there's nothing for
you here
it makes sense too why he would try to
go for someone way younger six years
younger yeah
also it's she's younger than him by six
years she's 23 and she's taking care of
all this yeah
[ __ ] you better get your ass out on the
street now yeah what the [ __ ]
find someone else yeah girl oh my god
there are better ones out there
oh no i mean he probably needs some help
but he also needs someone to stop
enabling him
like oh he's a drug addict so that makes
sense too so like they
like when you get addicted to drugs your
mindset changes to being
more selfish and you just aren't
thinking about anybody
why you're so selfish exactly so it does
make sense but
the only way to quit is for him to hit a
certain point a threshold where he wants
to stop
like where he wants to make a life
change and if you're providing
everything for him
there's no need to make a life change so
as shitty as it may be to you know start
again you're young
you're you're in your prime you got a
lot of [ __ ] going on
you could find someone that respects you
and loves you and doesn't lie to you
doesn't compare you to their exes does
it make you feel like [ __ ] about
yourself
it sounds like a lot of manipulation
going on which is just something you
don't need you don't need that in your
life
yeah at all mm-hmm you deserve better
back to the streets back to the streets
you go girl and you're going to save so
much money after you'll break up
you invest that make more money
good luck girlfriend all right next one
what's her name uh this one is mommy
milker's
one mommy milk or someone yeah she got
she got it
mommy milkers
not bad yeah here we go so it says
here's my should we break up story
disclaimer we're not actually together
we've been best friends for the past 10
years who have eventually began to start
having feelings for each other
he was my first kiss my first love
parentheses and lover
et cetera we both seem pretty committed
too for 10 years
um they've been best friends for the
past 10 years okay but they were
first love first kiss and they're not
together still well her first love
her first kiss her and lover uh they did
all this without being together
apparently so she'll explain so then it
says we both seem pretty committed to
each other and that we're
we aren't interested in seeing anyone
else the only reason why we aren't
together together is because he has a
lot of pressure from church
family that if he gets into a
relationship it has to be for marriage
he has to be ready to be a
husband-slash-father oh my god
i understood the need to wait when we
were 18 but now that we're both 25 i
feel like the clock is ticking
he says he's still not ready mentally
financially and spiritually
i get it but i'm tired of not telling
people he's my man
should i wait it out because i love him
or find someone who is ready
she's been like a dirty secret pretty
much oh no
oh no no sounds like it yeah no i
couldn't oh
yeah well how many years is that 18 to
25
as seven years yeah seven years
and then they were best friends for ten
years and yeah childhood
wow i mean you're like if you guys were
living together it'd be like state
oh yeah legally legally married yeah you
would have been legally married now
at that point oh my gosh or what is it
common law marriage
yeah that one's tough because i
understand like why
you are understanding and like why but
also like yeah i mean 25
it seems like it feels like you're an
adult do you
are you ready he needs some pressure put
on him because
like why wouldn't you why would why
doesn't he want to show you off to his
family or why wouldn't he want to stick
up for
your guys's relationship unless he
wasn't sure and then do you want to be
with someone that's not sure
yeah because if i was his family well i
mean like if i heard you know my son is
he's been friends with this girl since
childhood and they've been in each
other's lives 10 years
i'd be so excited i'd be so excited this
is actually really sweet you know but
then i could see like how i mean
she must be witnessing this if if
she understands that that's the pressure
that the family places on him
she must be also witnessing it too and
saying like
you know if this family is just saying
like well you better not be dating
anyone unless you're trying to get
married
and that's a lot of pressure to put on a
young
man that's just trying to figure his
[ __ ] out even though he is in a
loving relationship like secret
relationship with this chick but like to
have that amount of pressure i could see
why he's like
frozen like he can't make it but he's
25.
so you listen mommy milker
one um you have to decide if that's
worth
your happiness if you're okay with that
and
what if he i know you're not together
what if he breaks up with you how are
you gonna feel
about spending all of those years and
not even
getting like i guess credit i don't know
like a girlfriend label
yeah not even like you know you gave him
all of
your best like you're putting in more of
the effort of a relationship
and he won't even acknowledge that there
is a relationship yeah
you're giving him girlfriend things
without being his girlfriend
yes yeah a lot of girls i know a lot of
my girlfriends have done this and they
always regret it later because
they end up the guy ends up finding
someone who puts an ultimatum on
not an ultimatum but draws a line like
has standards that's like hey
if i'm gonna do this we're in a
relationship we're gonna call it that
you know you need to be able to stick up
to your family and say that
and he goes with that girl because they
have like
a backbone and like um they know what
they want
yeah and it sounds like this guy has
been like needing someone to know what
they want like right now he's listening
to his family who knows what they want
and so i think you need to kind of put
your put your foot down and like draw a
line
line in the sand and say hey i've done
this for seven years now
and i love you and i'm not really
willing to continue unless
this is gonna be an actual relationship
and we're gonna call it that and we're
gonna acknowledge that and you're gonna
stick up for me
and that might make him be like oh [ __ ]
like i don't want to lose this i do want
this
yeah it might give him some clarity and
he might actually
agree like you're right you know i want
to i want to make this a relationship
and if he doesn't then then that's your
answer yeah
for sure because yeah i mean him just
like
beating around the bush and not getting
to the point or not even confronting his
family it does
feel like wait so am i not important to
you exactly you want someone to value
you
enough like value you the way that you
value them
yeah and right now he's not he's not
showing that so
after seven years you would want to be
with someone who's like who loves you
enough to be able to be able to tell his
family like i don't care what you think
right this is the person that makes me
happy this is the person that i love and
want to be with
and if they can't do that like why would
you want to be with someone who's so
hung up on what their parents say
anyways at the end of the day it's his
life not his parents
so he needs to be able to stand for
himself and he doesn't have that
backbone you shouldn't even be with him
totally because like imagine later on if
you do get together
you have children and he just goes by
everything his mother says yeah
that would suck yeah oh really
like you're not i mean yeah they say
like once you marry someone you marry
their family too but this is like
literally like that exactly that's just
gonna put a strain in the relationship
think long term like big picture at the
end of the road
20 years from now what are you thinking
what's your picture look like
so tell him like look if you're not
gonna put a label on it i'm going back
to the streets
yeah cause damn you're still young yeah
yeah super young
good luck mommy milkers one yeah
the mommies they milk the mummies or the
is mommy's milkers these are mommy's
milkers
okay okay because that i took it as the
other way
oh yeah i know he's too much of a little
[ __ ] to do that anyways when you guys
are laying in bed
and you're just thinking you know what
now especially in this time it's spring
you know spring has sprung what else is
gonna sprung
well you can
you can bring the warmth of the outside
world back into your bedroom with dipsy
so shout out to our sponsor dipsy
dipsy is an audio app full of short sexy
stories designed
to turn you on each dipsy audio story
features characters that feel like real
people and immersive
scenarios so you feel like you're right
there
listen to stories about hooking up with
your hometown crush
you never made a move on or that
co-worker that you always had a little
thing for
or maybe a story that puts you in bed
with someone who's telling you exactly
what they'd like to do to you
they release new content every week so
there's always more to explore
no matter who you're into or what turns
you on and if you need to wind down
dipsy also has wellness sessions sensual
bedtime stories and soundscapes to help
you relax before you drift
off for listeners of this show dipsy is
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to dipsystories.com
mood that's 30 days of full access for
free
when you go to d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash mood
dipsystories.com
mood and once you've listened to these
stories
if you need a little if you still need
some help
we're also sponsored by bluechew which
is a men's tablet
service okay it's been a hell of a year
personally i feel like i've aged 12
years over the last
12 months and if you're like me you're
feeling your age more than you used to
especially in the bedroom time to snap
out of it though spring is here and it's
time to get sprung
yeah like tiff said um get your dick
hard
is what we're trying to say yeah yeah
[Laughter]
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable form
blue chews tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erections
to combat all forms of ed erectile
dysfunction
and it's an online prescription service
so no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations no waiting in line
at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package process is simple sign
up at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
the best part it's all done online so
you don't have to leave your dumb house
or the bedroom your dumb ass bitch-ass
house
like ridiculing you as i'm fixing you
the audience that's
that needs the bluetooth would like the
ridiculous they're signing up already
they like it
they're on the website right now so if
you could benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to perform visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code
big mood at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluechu.com
promo code big mood to receive your
first month free
and we thank blue chew for sponsoring
the podcast thank you
[Music]
all right guys what's the name of this
next
oh i'm asking this is butt flaps six
well butt flaps uh they write
hello picture they're right hello
i've been watching you girls for over a
year now and i would really appreciate
your advice
my boyfriend for watching yeah thank you
my boyfriend and i have been dating
since i was 18 years old
i am now 25 and he is 10 years 54.
oh oh well it's not a lot
so 47 when they got together 18 and 14
18 and 47.
dude i don't even think my dad was 47
when i was 18.
hold up wait what's 18 plus 18 my dad
was 40.
my dad was 42 when i was 18.
wow all right gosh
she says the past few years i find it
hard to be happy with him and have had
crippling anxiety over my future with
him i wanted to get married and have
kids but he would always tell me it was
never the right time
he has no kids of his own and has never
been married
the last two years have been extremely
difficult and i feel like i cannot even
hear him when he speaks to me
we haven't had sex in three years
because he has a mental block
and has not considered therapy even
though he has told me for the past year
that he will look into it
and go so he can be a better lover now
should i try to work it out with him or
head back to the streets back to the
streets back to the streets back to the
streets and take his [ __ ] walker
what the [ __ ] a gen z with a boomer
crazy 18 though and he was like what is
yo like what are you doing dating an 18
year old at that
time obviously he he keeps him young
yeah
well he never had kids and he never had
to worry about her
wanting marriage because she's so young
but now that she's getting to that point
he's like oh
yeah he didn't have to worry about that
she's getting too old for him yeah
but i wonder why he keeps her around
though because
he they haven't even had sex in three
years no no pretty young thing
just candy hasn't found an alternative
right
i don't know it sounds like i don't want
to i don't want to degrade your
relationship maybe like you did really
care about each other
but there is definitely something wrong
if in the past three years you've
haven't had wait no sex for three years
yeah no sex or little sex
oh my god even little no sex no oh no
i don't know don't haven't had sex
that's not a relationship to me
that i mean well okay it depends on like
not a relationship but
i don't know you're at 25 you again you
have to
decide for yourself if that's something
that you're willing to
to keep doing like are you willing what
if there is never any sex again
is that something that it's worth it for
you to keep going with
yeah because maybe it is but i don't
think
i could be in a relationship longer
if it had been that long without sex
[Music]
to me that's not really a sexual
partnership anymore clearly marriage is
what you want
and he doesn't want that so yeah why are
you still here when that is
i mean they must have like like intimate
issues
i mean intimate bonding stimulation
yeah exactly intimate situations that
nobody can barely hear him anymore
right so yeah i think like that they
have moved past
that point now she's at this breaking
point where she can no longer be in this
relationship it sounds like because
and she gets anxiety well she says that
she gets anxiety thinking about her
future with him
yeah which is very valid because you're
so young you have the rest of your life
ahead of you and you're going to be
with a man who doesn't want to provide
that future that you want for yourself
like
it's just like what's the point right
the relationship part is already
crumbling
so if you i mean i feel like it's just
sunken costs now
staying together like you're like okay
well i've been with them seven years
like i have to
stay together because it's already been
so long but you don't really have to do
that if you're not happy
and also i feel like actions speak
louder than words and so
him saying he's gonna go to therapy for
years but then not actually doing it
shows that he doesn't truly care about
that yep because if he did he would go
yeah so yeah i don't know to me
personally i would break up but i know
it's easier said than done yeah
so butt flap six like i hope that
you can really take a moment to think if
that's like something that you're
willing to
stick or stick around with right and
this is someone she's what it provides
you
she's she's been with him since 18 yeah
she's known for so long for your adult
life
yeah maybe she doesn't know that hey man
there's better it's better
maybe like onto the relationship yeah
yeah when you've like
spent your entire adult life with the
same person it is hard to
imagine yourself with anyone else or
even single yeah because you you've been
yeah kind of developed a codependency
after this long you deserve to be with
someone who like can't wait to marry you
yeah yeah who gives you the butterflies
and the excitement feeling and like
reciprocates right you being there for
them
that's true pack it up back it up back
to the streets get out of that
retirement home girl
come on now i mean i know the aarp
discount is great but
you're fine it's fine it's like three
bucks off your [ __ ] ihop meal it's
okay you're good
oh my god all right buff laps good luck
who's next
uh the next one is of a tow chewer 16.
yeah sounds painful and gross yeah
all right yeah well
because i pictured like cheesy feet
that's why i thought it was oh
gnawing on the toenail owie all right
anyway
well what was it trump told you or
submitting my story for advice my
boyfriend and i have been together for
seven years
high school street sweethearts street
hearts streets
streetcars um
and how many years uh seven years okay
high school sweethearts
and we have definitely grown so much in
the relationship both together and as in
individuals recently i felt like there's
no spark anymore and i'm not sure what
to do about it
we have our problems like most couples
do
i'm about to get my masters and have
started looking for a more long-term job
i want to move out by next year and get
our own place and really just kick start
the
next chapter in my life he is unemployed
after having lost his job two years ago
and struggled finding a job since
the issue is that he won't work just
anywhere and is very picky about his
options
i have basically been paying for most
things whenever we go out to eat do fun
things etc
but i'm so tired of it i shouldn't have
to literally say
get a job i don't want to keep paying
for everything anymore don't get me
wrong he has
goals but i feel like he's just waiting
for them to happen instead of actively
working towards them
he refuses to start at the bottom with
some mini minimum wage job
and thinks that he can just get to the
top without working hard
i'm just so tired of it and i don't know
what to do anymore he's waiting for it
to be handed to him
yeah it's pride and ego
i've subtly brought it up by saying that
i want to get our own place and start
traveling etc and he seems to be very on
board but then nothing happens
should i continue to have this
conversation again or should we just
break up he's on board with you paying
for it yeah
yeah he's like that sounds great and
then she says go she finishes off with
to clarify i don't mind paying for stuff
and holding it down when i need to
we're a team and i know he would do the
same for me but when is enough just
enough
yeah i mean they say that um
i think statistically finances is the
number number one thing that breaks
people up
yep and it's it's less about
not wanting to pay for them anymore but
more about feeling this
mutual support yeah or that there's like
like he cares about you enough to like
swallow his pride and work somewhere
else because it's something that would
help support you guys as a team
or it's like not even just like about
him caring about her it's about him
caring about himself and feeling like
he can better better himself too by
providing
a life for himself like why is he just
being like
a mom mama's boy pretty much like on the
couch just being cuddled letting
you pay for everything is just he sounds
like a spoiled little brat
yeah or entitled like he feels like
entitled to
not start at a lower level than what he
deems himself as
i know a lot of people like that too who
like they just see themselves as so much
higher than what they've actually
accomplished like if you if you were
that level then you would be able to
show it right and people just
i just don't think they're handing out
jobs to people that can't prove that
they can do the job
so um and if it's been two years yeah
like that's a long time
my here's the thing like my dad he owns
you know our nail salon
and he's been a business owner for the
last 20 something years when covid hit
in the nail salons
shut down he wasn't like no i'm too good
i'm a business owner
whatever no he went and he's like all
right i'll go get a job at
working uh the back stocking room at
walmart if i have to
yeah because he wants to work and
provide his there's no job above him
right like he's gonna man up and get a
[ __ ] job yeah you know yeah and
eventually you'll
get there but you can't just sit around
for two years and someone's just gonna
hand you a higher level job
yeah and maybe he just doesn't
understand that i don't know how he was
raised like maybe
he was kind of handed things growing up
and so he kind of expects that and
that's
unfortunately like not really his fault
but he has to acknowledge that and
kind of change his behaviors but um but
yeah
that's that's two holies are seven years
too yeah
the seven year itch thing exactly i
wasn't gonna say that yeah seven year
itch
i i feel like um if he was unemployed he
lost his job sure i get it but when it's
gotten to the point where you have to
actually say go get a job
yeah that is just so if
if i got to that point and someone had
to keep on saying that to me i would be
so embarrassed
yeah you know um and i'm a very
traditional person like i don't need a
man to take care of me
but i like a man who is like i'm going
to work i yeah who can provide
you know and how makes you feel
supported exactly
exactly so how do you feel good about
your girl in school she's working on her
master's you know she's still in school
and she's still paying for everything
for you
that's crazy you're a grown ass adult
you know and then there could be a
depression element too like sometimes
um i've been with a guy that
like he it's not that he lost his job he
was like a freelancer
and he there was a dry spell of like a
year
for where when i was i was like paying
for everything
and i didn't mind that but then he
i thought he was like i was just like
why isn't this dude getting a job
he got like really depressed and like he
was embarrassed and depressed that he
wasn't being able to provide but instead
of like
letting that fuel him to getting a job
he let that break him
into like just into a hole of of
depression so i don't know
exactly what um um toture's
guy is you're gonna remember the name
um but yeah uh that there could be that
reason too in which like
maybe he needs some some therapy maybe
he needs some talk space you can get a
hundred dollars off yeah she would have
to pay for it
yeah right you're saying
it's an investment at this point
investment yeah i feel like maybe at
this point since you're feeling like
you're just at the end of your rope like
a good strong stern talking
is warranted at this point where it's
like listen i can't do this anymore
we need to figure this out you need to
get out there and show me that you're
trying to
be my partner and not just be like my
[ __ ]
son yeah exactly give a timeline yeah
or discuss a timeline like how much is
fair
like can can maybe three months be a
goal for you to get a job listen no it's
covid everyone's hiring
yeah everyone's hiring like now that
everyone's got everything yeah yeah
everyone's hiring
and i if i were her and everyone's
hiring i don't want to hear well no that
job's not good enough for me
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you're broke work there
until you get the job you want exactly
and then work work like work just
[ __ ] get off your ass and work
i i would rather i respect someone who
works a minimum wage
job more than someone who's just
unemployed waiting for something thinks
they're better
the higher jobs yeah yeah yeah dude so
true
i worked with this guy who okay so we
were both waiters at the time this was
like when i was
21 22. and he was 30
and he was in sag and he was an actor
quote unquote
but he hadn't acted in anything but he
refused to do
any films for free like he wouldn't just
be in independent films or student films
or
or even work for like a hundred dollar
day rate which is like sag minimum
um because he thought of himself as like
a sag
actor who like you should always be
like paid for your work and like yes you
should at a certain point but
then why aren't you actors portfolio of
stuff you should be working instead of
working as a
waiter then but he wasn't even trying so
he was like
he was just yeah he was just kind of
like i'm
i'm just waiting until like the right
job gets handed to me basically
i think what is happening too underneath
all that for
those type of people is that they are
just so afraid of failure that they'd
rather not even try and fail
than try and get at least
somewhere than where they're at now like
they're just so stunted by their own
fear of failure that they won't move
yeah that's true yeah well i don't know
if it's a back to the streets yet i
think a discussion is definitely
warranted
and maybe a a timeline proposal and if
that's not
if if he doesn't follow through or like
show you
in some way that he cares then yeah it's
strong consideration
and you got to enforce that timeline too
yeah you can't just
get there and then he'll give you some
spiel and you're back at it you know
because girl you're you're working hard
you're working on that masters yeah
you're trying to better your future you
need a partner that can be there and
support you
you just supporting them it's draining
it's like having the weight on your
shoulders like why yeah
if you think about it too like if you
have kids with him and you guys are
struggling
okay you're gonna have to take care of
the kids too yeah and he's like no i
don't want to work that job because it's
just
not good enough for me like you don't
want to deal with or no i don't want to
i don't want to change the diaper
because it's beneath me
exactly it's not my job no yeah jeez i'm
not
i'm too overqualified for that yeah
all right well good luck good luck
yeah 16. okay next one who what's their
name
uh uh uh
broken hernia nine i'm glad it's broken
i'm like a broken hernia there you go
it's broken isn't that like
a fixed a burst okay burst burst hernia
nine there you go go ouch jesus birth
hernia nine what's up
all right let's just get more painful
triple ample triple amputee 14. let's go
okay it says hey big mood girls sending
my love from connecticut
this may be a long one and i've i'd like
to stay anonymous that's where the salem
witch trials were
whoa wasn't it massachusetts i'm a liar
salem massachusetts
salem organ all right
it says i've been with my boyfriend for
almost a year now
he is a goof but a love a loving and
caring partner
he matches my weirdness and makes me
laugh and goes out of his way to make me
happy
however he's not really the one i can
have deep conversations with
i'm all about opening up and talking
about my life feelings emotions people
etc
but with him i don't feel i i don't feel
really compelled to talk to him about
deep things
our conversations would be more shallow
like movies or shows we watch the little
things that happen in our daily lives
and things
along the lines of that it's not that he
can't
it's not that he can't because we have
had times where we had more meaningful
conversations but i had to initiate that
there were times i felt lonely despite
being in the relationship because i felt
like i wasn't fully understood by him
and i was suppressing all the emotions
that i didn't know how to express
despite being in a very
loving relationship where he provides
for me so much i'm still questioning
about
whether this is the right relationship
for me which makes me feel ungrateful
for what he has done for me
and i worry that if i do separate with
him because of this reason i might be
making a big mistake and i'll regret it
down the line for letting go of someone
who loves me so much
would love your latest ladies advice
thank you so much
wow that's a really tough one did she
say how old she was
no okay um i feel like
i had the opposite situation where we
could have deep conversations but the
guy wasn't
he couldn't make me laugh like he was
not funny
um and i was getting more attracted to
guys that
were intelligent that also like were
funny and
had a sense of humor and it was so hard
because the dude i was with was like a
so
super supportive loving guy he would
have been there
for me forever but and we had been
together for five years but i just like
couldn't he i needed that funniness
and um it ended up like with me not
being sexually attracted anymore and
then that's when it was really over and
but it was super hard because it was
like he's a good guy i'm comfortable
he gets me he understands me what if i
never find
anyone like that like what if just this
one thing missing
is like i'm just asking for too much
but i had to i had to i could it wasn't
fair to him
that i was getting stimulated by other
people
and i think that's my maybe what you're
going through where if you
can even acknowledge that
you're you can't have stimulating
conversation with him or you're you
don't feel comfortable
that means you have had it with other
people yeah because you
you know that it's out there you know
what you're missing yeah
and i don't think it's like really
fair to him if you like
are getting this need met by other
people i don't know and then it's not
fair to you that you
can't ever get that need met if you stay
with him right
i'm very big on communication you know i
think we all are communication's such a
huge thing for us
and i a lot of times those deep
conversations is where love
stems yeah and that bonding happens as
bonding happens
um and you when you're old and gray your
looks are gone
you know and and things are
all you have left is conversation and
and loving conversation like what are
you guys gonna talk about [ __ ] bingo
every [ __ ] night of the week yeah
so that that deep conversation
connection is what you absolutely need
and i feel like
have you spoken to him about this kitty
poo club takes care of the more
unpleasant parts of cat ownership so you
can get back to loving your furry friend
i have four furry friends at my house
it's a party come
over kitty boo club kitty poo club is a
convenient all-in-one monthly litter box
solution and every month kitty poo club
delivers an affordable
high quality recyclable litter box
that's pre-filled with the litter of
your choice this is so key because like
so the kitty litter box you have to
scoop it but then like you have to clean
it out once
you actually scrub it gets nasty with
the urine and it's disgusting so that's
why i love this
this is great you can just recycle the
litter box throw it out you can
pick the litter that you want the boxes
are leak proofs they're eco-friendly and
they have a fun design for every season
you can also customize your order based
on how many cats you have choose from
four different litter types so i have
all four
so when the month is up just recycle the
box not the litter
but the box and kitty poo club will
automatically deliver a new one to you
no changing use litter no more cleaning
the box kitty poo club also has a no
risk satisfaction guarantee and you can
easily customize or cancel any time
and right now kitty poo club is offering
you 20 off your first order plus a free
dome
free scoop and free shipping you uh when
you set up autoship by going to
kittypooclub.commu just go to
kittypooclub.com
mood to get 20 off your first order plus
a free dome scoop and free shipping when
you set up autoship
that's kittypoo club.com mood
guess what what it's 2021 yeah
i didn't know that you had time in 2021
for
uncomfortable shoes i don't look at
these
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass shoes i got on
right now
i do not have time yeah look you've got
uncomfortable shoes no these are
uncomfortable okay well you had to break
those but i had to break
we all got a free pair to try before we
were the ad to decide if we were gonna
to do to do this adderall not asleep in
them as soon as i put my foot in that
[ __ ] i was like oh hell yeah it feels
like a
socks but like stronger mm-hmm but then
it's still got like the
shoe sole and stuff so it's like very
strong you do your activities yeah so
crazy that they're this comfortable but
they're made out of recycled water
bottles
yeah what it's crazy so there's a ton of
sustainably
made styles and it's fully machine
washable
tons of shapes too like so i got the
flat pointed toe ones but they have like
tennis shoes yeah yeah i got a sneaker
like but they're like sock tennis shoes
they're so
crazy um pop sugar named rothy's one of
the most
comfortable and cute flats you'll never
tire of wearing
rothy's best-selling shoe the point in
black has over 5 000 near-perfect
reviews
upgrade your closet with washable
sustainable stylish shoes and bags from
rothy's
plus they just launched men's shoes so
make sure to check them out for you
or the guy in your life head to
rothys.com big mood to find your new
favorites today
that's r-o-t-h-y-s
raw fees dot com slash big mood so going
back to this right yeah what was i sing
yeah so we're communication right the
communication is very important
but i also feel like if she really i
don't know if she's talked to him about
it yet and told him because he seems
like a fun understanding guy
and if he had a conversation with him
and said hey like this is really what i
want
i feel like people can learn how to
communicate better that's exactly what i
was gonna say
because like she says that she is able
to have meaningful conversations with
yeah but the thing that she doesn't like
is that she has to initiate that and i
completely relate to that like i or i
used to relate because that's how
it was with me and casey like for him
it's not that we couldn't have like deep
meaningful conversations but
it was the same thing where like i
always had to initiate
like to dig in because he had a lot of
issues on how to communicate
and that caused like a lot of
miscommunication between us a lot of
like resentment built up and
so if you can if you're able to
recognize that already
then you can have a conversation and
like teach him how
you would like to have meaningful
conversations if he which sounds like he
would be
open to hear that yeah so it doesn't
seem like a
back to the streets for me personally it
just seems like you just have to have a
conversation with him about how
this is important to you and obviously
he's not incapable of doing it since you
have had meaningful conversations right
that's that was the one tell where i was
like
okay maybe there is hope because when i
had the conversation my
ex-boyfriend could not be funny and it
was just kind of cringy
but if there is hope like he has been
able to have deep conversations then
maybe it's just a matter of
kind of like letting it flow more like
maybe there's a blockage that's stopping
him from expressing himself more
from something in his past or maybe
something like he just wasn't raised to
freely talk like that he was ridiculed
when he tried in the past and
like humor has been like the way he yeah
puts a wall up
so as i was asking about the age because
if you guys are both young like that's
easy to like start
opening up and training but even if
you're older like it
there's still hope there yeah so for
sure
yeah i hope things work out with your
hernia too yeah yeah the first the
bursting
you don't got to go back to the streets
so but do what that is
do you deal with the hernia yeah the
funny dude to
make jokes about it all right
uh next one who do we have uh
butthole gate no number oh they got the
first one i got the first one
they are the first butthole game yeah it
doesn't really have a ring to it that's
not okay
it sounds like a conspiracy theory the
gate yeah
it's just a crack there's a little slit
it's conspiracy
what do we really know about butts
[Laughter]
oh man that's funny have you ever seen
it yeah like really really
you never saw steve's how do we know
everything's real
all right butt cape all right so they're
right this guy
this guy and i are not in a full-on
relationship yet but there are many
things that confuses me
he does see a future with me but we both
happen to end things with our
significant other at the same time when
we started talking
okay number one i am scared that he he'd
cheat on me because when i first met him
it was supposed to be a hookup
he had already set his mind with the
girl but ended up keeping in contact
with me after that day
there would be times where he'd asked me
to go over or say sexual things when he
and his girl were official so that makes
me think
what like that makes me think wouldn't
he do that to me yeah
i would think the same things number two
i think this has been the most
healthiest talking stage i've had with a
guy
we always communicate about problems and
never gaslight each other
when something is wrong we he always
apologizes
and actually improves okay we also do
not call or text every day and every
minute for some healthy distance
but when we are together in person he is
never on his phone and i'm always able
to have his undivided attention oh
that's pretty good
i am just very confused if i am
paranoid or if this is not worth to ha
to like uh to hand onto
to hang on to also thank you for the
podcast because my mental health
improving
have had a lot to do with you girls i
always feel like i have some sisters to
turn to
i am literally at my highest point of
happy and couldn't have been
without listening to your podcast daily
oh that's really sweet thanks
which actually by the way a lot of these
messages started like they were telling
us like how where
were their sisters i love that that's
not exactly love that
what i was hoping for that like when we
started in the group chat
i was like i wish i had this exactly
when i was growing up
yeah yeah so thank you guys we love you
guys
so okay well do they say their age did
they say
no age okay it didn't start off strong
that's for sure but she said older
sisters so maybe she's younger than us
uh she just said sisters oh okay well
maybe i'm gonna give this guy a big
benefit of the doubt
i would have the same concerns as you
because that's it's like okay he's
already proven that he can be shady
so what makes me think i'm special but
sometimes there's just a learning curve
like
for example steve everyone is like whoa
he's such a good guy blah blah blah
but like he was kind of shitty to his
exes like some of his ex not all of his
exes
he was really good for two of them but a
couple of them way back then
when or like you know one night stand
type things that he
just like kind of was using people
as a revenge tool or whatever um like
those girls probably wouldn't say he's a
good guy but it doesn't mean that he's
not a good guy it's just that
those weren't the ones for him and he
feels bad about what he did
but it just wasn't he would never do
that to me
so you i'd really have to know the guy
right so the thing about this kind of
okay so it started off
not great there's a reason to not trust
him already yeah yeah and i understand
that when he's with you he's
on his phone he gives you your undivided
attention i knew a guy once he was never
on his phone
because he couldn't be around his phone
around this girl
in case she sees anything and also the
the healthy distance
yeah for me was kind of like that sounds
like a good thing but it could also be a
red flag
not texting and talking every day maybe
it's because he's with someone else okay
is it not texting and talking every day
but if you were to text him he responds
right away
or is it like he just doesn't he leaves
you on red for like
three days yeah so this is already
starting off rocky i'm the pessimistic
side of me is like
yeah and then plus also she says oh well
the talking stage is so healthy talking
stages are usually healthy yeah because
that's when you're putting
your best foot forward right yeah so you
can't really judge me
mm-hmm the roast to do glasses just yet
you know
how long has it been did they say
they're not even together yet yeah but
how long have they been in this
i don't think she mentioned this i don't
think she mentioned it i thought she
said at the beginning like it was like
kind of a long time
uh it just says that they're not in a
full-on relationship yet
oh that's all that yeah so my brain
filled in that yeah butt gape
filled up that gate yeah yeah because
they're just they're not in a
relationship they're just talking
it's just that that he she has already
hooked up with him and when she hooked
up with him
he had his official with someone else
right or like eventually he became
official with someone else when they
were just
keeping in contact after yeah that's
what happened after so he didn't
like officially cheat on that other girl
no he said no no
yes he said uh that he'd asked me to go
over again
or say sexual things when he was with
the government oh
no yeah oh no yeah yeah i don't know
like
i mean this i can't help but think of
the guy that gina has talked about and
it just sounds like stuff that that dude
would do to gina or to other girls i
mean
and it just sounds really fishy there's
a lot of red flags there
and i know you're trying to give them
the benefit of the doubt but personally
if you're already starting off with the
suspicion
and it's just like why even continue
down that road right right
right because then it's always going to
be in the back of your mind
yeah because the talking stage is
healthy but then there's also this issue
here
you can have or or you can have someone
else with a very healthy talking stage
also
and no issue over here right you're
right he's going to be suspicious you're
always going to think like
yeah well can i even trust him and then
what's the what's the point of even
starting a new relationship if you're
not even going to enter it with trust
exactly it's just true you're literally
you enter it as the st
as the side chick yeah yeah
that's not healthy that's not a good
foundation that's going to be
a rocky house to build on you know for
yeah and i think if the standard
is just like well he doesn't guess like
me right like that's like
he doesn't let his phone below standard
that's
minimum bare minimum like yeah you
really yeah you should
shouldn't be with someone that gaslights
you for sure but the fact that he
doesn't it doesn't make him like
prince charming yeah i think the reason
why she's like well this is good and
healthy is because
he actually apologizes and improves but
that could just be like i mean obviously
the improvement is a great thing and
it's like okay awesome
but the apologizing it could just be
like him covering his ass
i don't know yeah also how are those
there are this many things to apologize
for in the very beginning already
true and are they like very big like
fundamental things or just like
sorry your chips i won't do anything
yeah yeah right right
yeah so there's a lot of holes here a
lot of butt gapes there's a lot of
buckets in this story that needs to be
filled in i always just say back to the
streets girl
yeah it's not worth it yeah early it's
just so not working to do this much
dissecting in the very beginning oh my
goodness yep
yep that's a lot of pieces to a puzzle
your bags pack those bags
or keep them packed in the corner i mean
you were still kind of sorted in the
streets you guys weren't together
yeah yeah yeah grab your bag yeah look
at other doorsteps you can you can do
better
all right well is that is that everyone
i feel like
that wasn't too bad like we didn't there
was some there were some that weren't
back to the streets
yeah still in their homes yeah so we
don't hate men yeah
well well this one's the one that you
know that's not here my
hands on here no she's gotten a less men
hater yeah
she had to get out of her system yeah
she was just a few of these she would
have raged at for sure
for sure yeah um we miss you jess
we were pretty nice to the gentlemen
that were being spoken about
today even the ones that we disagreed
with
yep however and then there's still more
submissions so
i mean if you guys didn't hear your
story
don't worry we'll definitely be doing
more of these we'll do more of these and
if so it's not too late to submit as
well so yeah always
at big mood girls on instagram that is
the majority of where we take the
stories because it's just really easy to
collect questions that way
and be sure to subscribe and
rate us five stars on itunes or whatever
that and also check out our sponsors
that's how we pick your stories yeah as
well yeah you make make your account on
the
site and butt gape something so we know
it's you so we know it's you yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right thank you see you
next time bye
bye